Speaker 1: Today.
We're going to be speaking with Dan Cannon,
who's a civil rights lawyer and a law professor
at the University of Louisville.
He's also author of the book Pleading Out
How Plea Bargaining Creates a Permanent Criminal
Class.
Dan, really great having you on.
I appreciate your time.
Speaker 4: Hi, David.
Thanks for having.
Speaker 1: Me.
So, I mean, I think maybe to start it would
it would make sense to talk about how this
sort of like a plea deal industrial complex
started.
I think many of us intuitively know just because
you've been charged with a crime doesn't mean
that there will eventually be a trial and
a verdict in the way that we watch sometimes
on television in major trials.
How did this develop that many cases don't
make it to trial?
Whose motive?
Who was motivated to make that the reality?
Speaker 4: Sure.
And I would I would go so far as to say almost
all cases don't make it to trial.
Where we're sitting at right now is a 97%
plea bargain rate, which is, you know, just
to sort of grasp the how big that is.
You know, that's that's three out of every
out of every hundred criminal cases that might
go to trial.
Right.
You know, on average.
And that's the entire country.
This is way, way, way far beyond what anybody
else is doing in the rest of the world.
The rest of the world, you know, even in comparable
legal systems, places like the United Kingdom
and Canada and so on.
I mean, the highest you get is to 80%.
And even that is kind of extreme.
So nobody does it as much as we do.
And and the result has been pretty much the
death of the jury trial altogether.
For all intents and purposes, the community
has been completely removed from processes
of criminal justice.
And if you look historically at how and why
this originated, you know, this uniquely American
thing that we do.
You got to go back all the way to the beginning
of the 19th century and look at the early
labor movement in the United States.
And when that was gathering steam, that is
at the same time that that is the same time
that the plea bargain sort of took off in
New England.
Right.
So you have this post-industrial revolution
situation where the working classes are getting
bigger and bigger and bigger and bigger.
And up until 1830, you know, plea bargaining
was taboo.
There was I mean, you would see prosecutors
actually get prosecuted for trying to make
deals with defendants in the way that they
do now.
So it was completely off the table and just
wasn't happening.
Or if it was happening, we didn't know about
it.
Then in Massachusetts, you see that number
tick up very quickly by the 1850s.
It's 50% of all criminal cases are ending
in a guilty plea.
By the 1880s, it's 88%.
Right.
So almost all criminal cases are ending in
a guilty plea by the end of the 19th century
in Massachusetts.
And what's happening there is that there's
this this giant explosion of working class
people.
Right.
And at the beginning, in the 1830s, the courts
and every other American institution is working
really, really hard to break the back of organized
labor.
You've got the first strikes are happening
in the 1820s, and then the first Federation
of Labor Unions happens in New York in 1834.
And so the ruling classes are sort of panicking
and coming, trying to figure out, you know,
how to how to fix this whole thing.
First thing they start doing is prosecuting
groups of workers under conspiracy statutes.
So you get big groups of time to say, all
right, you know, you're going to get together
and try to get higher wages or, you know,
a shorter workdays or something like that.
We're going to prosecute you for a conspiracy.
And it becomes pretty apparent early on that
that's that's not going to work by the 1840
days.
They've sort of scrapped that whole idea because
there's just too many of them.
And there's the working classes are getting
too big and there's working class people for
the first time sitting on these criminal juries.
So the response of the ruling classes at that
time is, as I talk about in my book, is to,
number one, take a lot of power away from
juries.
Juries are not nearly as powerful now as they
were back then.
And the other one is to introduce the plea
bargain.
So what that allows them to do is to quickly
and quietly prosecute lots of individual workers
one by one, rather than trying to smack a
whole bunch of them at a time with the hammer
of the criminal law, which they knew that
wasn't going to work.
They were just too outnumbered.
Speaker 1: In the modern era.
What is the advantage?
We'll talk first about the prosecutors.
I mean, it seems if everybody went to trial,
they would not have nearly the work force
that would be required to try that number
of cases.
Right.
I mean, it just seems like an impossibility.
Speaker 4: Yeah.
Yeah.
So what you see in situations where the in
the few situations where you've actually reduced
the number of plea bargains is that it does
force prosecutors to make tough decisions.
So you look at the historical example of Alaska
for a very brief period of time in Alaska,
you had an attorney general come in and say,
you know, this is we're going to stop doing
plea bargaining.
We're going to reduce the number of plea bargains
like all the plea bargains are going to come
through me.
Yep.
And and what I've heard since I was in law
school is that if somebody does something
like that, it's going to crash the whole system.
Right.
We're just not going to have a criminal justice
system anymore because the wheels of justice
are going to stop turning.
And, you know, all these jury trials are going
to make it to where we just can't do anything.
Right.
But that's not true.
If you look at the historical example of Alaska
and some of these other places where this
has happened, what happened in Alaska was
lots more cases went to trial, but the system
didn't crash.
It adapted and it got more intelligent.
So at the point in time in Alaska, where this
new attorney general took over, the Alaskan
prosecutors were rejecting about 4% of all
the cases that police brought to them.
So cops will come in with a case and it was
a bad case.
If it was a good case, it didn't matter because
the prosecutors knew that they could push
somebody into some kind of plea bargain and
get a conviction.
Right.
Taking plea bargaining off the table means
that the prosecutors have to be more selective.
And so what happens right off the bat is that
the prosecutors go from rejecting 4% of all
those cases to rejecting 40% of them.
So that forces prosecutors to to make decisions.
Right.
To come up with priorities for what they're
going to prosecute and what they're really,
you know, what the community's priorities
really are.
And and so far from crashing this system,
it adapts.
It becomes more intelligent.
The prosecutors are making more intelligent
decisions.
And that forces the police to cross their
T's and dot their eyes and do more diligent
homework.
So if you think about the situation that we
have now, you know, police know they're going
to get a conviction.
They know that they're going to you know,
they they out of most of the 11 million arrests
that happen in the United States every year
are going to result in some kind of conviction.
And so they don't have to have any real evidence
that a crime was committed.
They don't have to you know, they're not anticipating
that they're ever going to be put on the stand
or have to account for the charges that they've
levied against somebody in any meaningful
way.
And and if you reduce the number of plea bargain
cases, even just by a little bit, that whole
situation starts to change.
Because police know that the case is more
likely to go to trial.
And so they have to be more careful in what
they bring to prosecutors in the first place.
Speaker 1: Now, from the standpoint of the
defendants, the accused, I think many of us
have this instinct that if we were ever in
such a situation and we felt that we were
innocent, we would fight to the end and demand
a jury trial and so on and so forth.
What are the incentives that are there for
those who are charged to end up taking plea
deals?
Speaker 4: Well, it's every incentive in the
world, isn't it?
You know, so so that's what we've decided
to do in the United States.
That's so different from the rest of the world.
Here.
We decided that we're going to give every
carrot and every stick to prosecutors so they
can end up with conviction somehow.
Right.
So this was all still sorting itself out by
the late 20th century.
And then there was this Supreme Court case
called Bordon Carter versus Hayes, where you
have right down the road here in Lexington,
Kentucky, you've got a 29 year old black horse
transporter who gets picked up for trying
to cash a bad check worth $88.
Right.
So he writes a bad check.
The prosecutor comes to him, says, well, it
looks like you were in trouble ten years ago
over something.
And so what you're going to do is for this
$88 check, you're going to take five years
in prison.
And Paul Hayes says, I don't want to take
five years in prison.
Prosecutor says, Well, if you don't take five
years in prison, then I'm going to hit you
with this habitual offender charge and that
carries a mandatory penalty of life in prison.
And he's like, I don't want to do life in
prison over an $80 check.
But that's the kind of power the prosecutor
has.
We're still sort of sorting out whether or
not we wanted to do that.
In that case, Paul Hayes didn't want to take
the deal.
He went to trial, got convicted and got a
life sentence.
And that case went all the way up to the Supreme
Court.
And the Supreme Court at that time in 1978,
essentially says, yeah, you know, it's the
prosecutor's job to persuade a defendant to
give up their right to trial.
And they can do that by hook or by crook.
They can do whatever they want to get a defendant
to to to plead guilty and to forego the, as
the prosecutor says, the inconvenience of
the trial.
And so that case sort of throws the floodgates
open for prosecutors to use anything and everything
that they want.
So, you know, if you have if you're charged
with murder, let's say, you know, the prosecutor
can offer carrots.
You can say, look, you know, we're going to
bust these charges down to a wanton endangerment
and you're going to do six months probation
because I just don't want to take it to trial.
And I don't think it's a very good case.
But I need a conviction.
So, you know, take it or leave it.
And you'd be hard pressed to say, I'm going
to leave that on the table.
Conversely, if a prosecutor wants to proceed
as though it is a death penalty case and threaten
a defendant with literal death if they don't
take a plea bargain to, let's say, life without
prison, they can do that, too.
And in fact, when you look at the numbers,
one of the more chilling statistics that I've
got in my book is that since the 1970s, 75%
of the people on death row could have avoided
a death sentence by taking the plea offer
that the prosecutor gave to them.
So in other words, the prosecutor has the
power to say, you know, if you don't take
this deal, I'm going to put the death sentence
on the table.
It's not on the table until you take it, until
you say yes or no.
But if you make me go to trial, well, death
penalty is on the table.
So prosecutors just had this enormous power
to alter the legal landscape in any given
case that in the United States that they just
don't have in other countries.
Speaker 1: Is it easier for wealthier defendants
to avoid taking plea deals in the sense that
all else being equal, a long trial costs more
money?
Speaker 4: Sure.
For for for reasons that I said before, long
trials cost more money.
But they're also, you know, more high profile.
Right.
They're more visible to the public.
The media pays more attention to what's going
on in these high profile cases.
So you get somebody like a Jeffrey Epstein
that's going to come in with you know, it's
quite obviously is is is guilty, but comes
in with a team of, you know, 100 high paid
lawyers that are going to make the prosecution
work for for anything that they end up with.
And so the prosecutor starts to look at that
situation saying, all right, this is going
to be very time consuming, is going to be
very difficult.
It's going to be very expensive.
And it could be very humiliating if we lose.
Right.
You know, this this this could have political
consequences and all this other stuff.
And it's going to be very much in the public
eye.
So rather than go through, you know, the the
hoops of a trial, let's try to get them into
a place where they're going to take a plea.
And in fact, that is exactly what happened
down in Florida with Jeffrey Epstein and the
initial disastrous prosecution they tried
to carry on their.
And in the victims were completely cut out
of that prosecution.
And Epstein got a slap on the wrist for, you
know, abhorrent conduct.
And that is the kind of treatment that the
wealthy typically can expect to receive in
the United States.
So when people talk about there being two
different justice systems here, that's that's
what they mean.
Speaker 1: It seems the other component to
this also is the use of pretrial detention
and the ability to make bail.
I mean, as a very general concept, I think
it's probably more difficult to mount a defense.
All else being equal, if you are being detained
up until the time of your trial rather than
out.
Can you talk a little bit about that and the
effect of pretrial detention and possibly
the unequal application of pretrial detention
on the sort of plea bargain chances, I guess?
Speaker 4: Sure.
So cash bail, like the plea bargain is one
of those things that we've carried forward,
you know, from an overtly class system in
the 19th century until now.
Right.
So it's yet another gun that a prosecution
that the prosecution can put to a defendant's
head to say, like, listen, you know, if you
don't take this deal, you're just going to
stay locked up there until we have a trial.
And that could be two years from now.
That could be three years from now.
So if you can't post bail.
Tough luck there.
You sit in the county jail and these county
jails, as I'm sure you know, are oftentimes
not friendly places.
They're so unfriendly, in fact, and especially
metropolitan jails are so unfriendly that
you see defendants taking deals where they
end up going to prison just because prisons
are a little friendlier than the county jail
right now, for example.
You see that a lot.
But but basically, it's it's this arsenal
of tools that the prosecution has.
Cash bail being one of them to make sure that
that that every defendant gets pressed into
taking a deal of some kind.
I had a client that I represented in a civil
rights case who insisted on his innocence
in in these criminal charges that were levied
against him way out in rural Kentucky.
And he sat there in jail waiting for his trial
to come up for three years.
Well, the maximum sentence that he could have
come up with, that he could have been subjected
to was only two years while on the original
charges.
So he sits there in three years waiting for
his trial and then goes to trial and no police
show up and they dismiss the charges, you
know.
And so that is the kind of thing that for
people that insist on their right to trial,
they're going to get punished for it.
And it's what we call the trial penalty is
what happened to Paul Hayes.
It's what's happened to countless clients
that I've had.
And it's what happens all over America every
single day in those situations.
Speaker 1: I think this was an issue with
with Donziger.
In fact, when the strictest penalty you could
get is less than the time that you've been
detained pretrial.
Is there some recourse to remedy in those
cases?
Speaker 4: Well, you'd think there would be.
Yeah, you'd think that.
And that's that was, you know, the case with
my guy down in eastern Kentucky.
Yeah.
But the federal courts are so hostile in most
of the country to these civil rights actions
that you're not very likely to get anywhere.
And especially since this is such a common
thing for people to stay in jail way longer
than they should stay in jail for one reason
or another.
Yeah.
That, you know, most most of those folks that
have been aggrieved by something like that
in the system can't even find a civil lawyer
to represent them to to to vindicate their
rights.
Certainly not in rural parts of the country
where this happens all the time.
And when they do find someone to represent
them, the civil rights actions tend to fall
flat on their face because you've got these
judges that are hostile to these kinds of
actions to begin with.
Speaker 1: Right.
The book is pleading out how plea bargaining
creates a permanent criminal class.
We've been speaking to the book's author,
law professor Dan Cannon.
Dan, thank you so much for your time.
Speaker 4: Thanks so much for having me.